[Música]
olá eu sou sônia barbosa faz teatro como
atriz é e comentadora também como
criadora de espetáculos isso a
professora de teatro ano na área do
teatro aqui na reserva e estou aqui
burra tenho medo quero começar por dizer
isto
cheia de medo muito feliz e agradeço
desde já o convite da organização da
tese e em particular da nba está na
itália banana que me convidou
quando ela me convidou eu fiquei ao
mesmo tempo muito surpreendida e algo o
radar porque já vi várias testes na
internet e sempre foram muitas são
referências importantes pra mim ainda
estiver ver uma do que jovens sendo que
é o senhor que é um especialista em
educação criatividade que tem uma
técnica maravilhosa não sei se a vila
mas não viram vão ver e pensei uau e
agora que eu vou fazer uma técnica ainda
é possível depois ela mesmo tema e o
adeafi tchan
tu és o futuro e eu tecnologia cenas
digital eu sou uma mulher do teatro que
as pessoas conhecem sabem por ser muito
pouca tecnologia estou sempre a gente ia
sair do facebook falar e é isso que faz
a fazer casa desperdiçar a sua vida e
pensei estou tramado o que é que eu vou
fazer e fica cheio de medo continua
agora neste momento cheio de medo
estou muito feliz porque o júlio falou
tudo aquilo que eu não vou falar do
futuro e diz eu não sei o que vai ser
futuro nunca foi multada a imaginar o
futuro a pensar quando gostar daqui a 10
anos e pensei estudou teatro e pensei o
que eu posso fazer para para falar sobre
o futuro com minha experiência que eu
posso dar estas pessoas é que estão a
olhar pra mim
e que o meu objetivo é dar lhes alguma
coisa do teu inspirar alguma maneira e
pensei o que eu vou fazer o que eu vou
fazer disse
vou ler os mandamentos do teto até nos
mandamentos eu disse é isso que vai
salvar eu vou ler mandamentos e vai ser
aquilo que vai ajudar a fazer uma
apresentação espetacular e então uma
delas um dos mandamentos disso não
ultrapassar o tempo e eu pensei tenho
provado daquelas alarmes
é claro que usamos para cozinhar faz
bibi porque eu a minha coisa é a
primeira noção do tempo principalmente
quando envolve com uma coisa começa a
entusiasmar que espero que aconteça
agora eu perco a noção do tempo eo tempo
voa e alguém dispara já acabou eo não
descritas importantes vão rolar mas
prefiro não falar o senhor mesmo tempo à
frente por conta de problemas que
estariam muito obrigado a cometer mas o
jorge está aqui pra te salvar a vida vai
em 15 minutos ok disse então o tempo
está eu vou respeitar o tempo costa este
mandamento outro mandamento tenho que
preparar a tutela ensaia junto com um
amigo de confiança que se dê feedback e
eu pensei vou respeitar este mandamento
porque vão ficar doida e as pessoas que
me conhecem sabem mas não só por isso
porque pensei é coisa que talvez eu
possa trazer para aqui da minha área e
propor é é potencializado do do
conhecido da improvisação uma coisa que
nós usamos muito nós usamos muito no
teatro o que pode acontecer se eu não me
preparar muito assustador meus queridos
eu estou aqui também porque eu não sei o
que vai acontecer eu posso simplesmente
ter uma branca e ficar calada durante os
próximos 14 minutos e 31 dias e disse
vou experimentar isso vou tentar colocar
numa situação em que embora eu saiba o
que quer falar eu não tenho a minha
apresentação seguida e vou olhar para
aquelas pessoas e vou tentar que se
possa ser uma forma de u própria e
obrigar a comunicar e foi isso que eu
fiz não pára por aí agora estou aqui
continua a mexer medo de pensar não
estou tramado estaleiros o fraga olhar
pra mim
e está aí o paulo olhar pra mim isto vai
ser uma grande arrancada ele só cai
calma sônia calma senhora então não tem
por missão empresarial futuro não não
sei o que o futuro mas sei que a
previsão se baseia no aqui e agora e
pensei espera lá o aqui agora aquilo que
está presente e olhar a minha volta o
olhar para as pessoas que jogar com o
que está a acontecer agora é uma das
regras da improvisação e é isso que não
tenha ajudado sempre decidir o que vou
fazer no futuro
e pensei nesta era em que todos estamos
preocupados como é que vai ser o que eu
vou fazer
que tal pensarmos um carinho no que é
que eu sou
depois disso pensar em o título tu és o
futuro em vez de pensar em futuro
deixando pensar em tudo és tu és ser nós
somos kills o que é que tu és tu é um
espaço que para mim começa cada vez mais
a fazer falta é difícil saber quem sou
quando não têm tempo sequer me perguntar
e muito tempo de procurar dar resposta e
então nesta era digital em que nós
abrimos janela vamos atrás das outras e
temos resposta para tudo como dizia acho
que o julguem dizia que a informação
está aí e e tudo tudo o que nós queremos
saber está indisponível
o problema está pois nem escolher a
informação numa e tanta e tão eu
proponho uma outra coisa e propõe que em
vez de encontrar soluções procurar
procurar a era digital é mais fácil mas
desde aquela coisa do fly falar em vez
disso penso em outra coisa que é o vazio
o silêncio
e temos aqui um sorriso incrível estamos
a improvisar e 8 joão há um estudo que
eu gosto muito que se chama peter bruck
e que num dos seus livros diz nada de
extraordinário pode acontecer nós não
criamos um espaço vazio
isto que no teatro é muito verdade em
todos e em todas as coisas é muito
rodado
eu não posso ser
se não derem espaço
eu não posso perguntar o que é que eu
gosto que me faz sentir bem que não é
provocar raiva que me entristece é que o
desejo eu não consigo perguntar se quer
essas perguntas muito me encontrar uma
resposta sem esses vazios em silêncio
sem esse espaço
então em vez de pensar no futuro vamos
pensar no aqui e agora vamos pensar no
no que eu sou eo que eu quero abrir esse
espaço entre outro porque começamos a
descobrir que o nosso futuro e ela já
disse isso aqui
o futuro é uma abstração o que é o
futuro o futuro é agora o futuro é agora
o futuro é agora o futuro está sempre a
acontecer e única coisa que pode mudar o
futuro e as escolhas que o tomo a emoção
eu no presente porque nosso futuro
constrói-se de milhares de decisões
cotidianas decisões decisões mas atrás
das outras que se vocês não estimar em
alguém vai contar para vocês
tu não sabe que curso é que quer chances
que não sabe que profissão quer discutir
ontem não tem a certeza sei por que
proibir isto não tomar essa decisão olha
vai transmitir o pai e mãe os amigos o
grupo de opção 77 e por fora as decisões
modo a nossa vida e quanto mais
capacidade nós temos de perceber que
podemos escolher
mas o futuro será nosso o meu futuro
será o meu futuro
e acreditem que acho que a única coisa
que nós temos de certo para além de
morte é nossa vida
ninguém pode viver a nossa vida por nós
ninguém pode saber o que é ser eu eu só
sei que é ser eu e só o jorge sabe o que
é ser o jorge e etc
portanto não deixem a vossa vida na na
mão de outra pessoa que precisa o que
vão fazer e como é que vai fazer a
escolha não escolheram a principal forma
de construir o futuro é escolher
escolher o que eu quero a partir de uma
de uma noção am algo sério e profundo
que eu sou ou seja é um carinho uma
mistura entre é tirar de cabeça como eu
que se vive pra que centenas preparado e
uma consciência que vai mexendo com
experiência de do que eu sou e do que a
que corresponde o que eu vejo a minha
volta do que eu acho que vale a pena
investir o meu esforço e minha atenção é
uma mistura dessas duas coisas e por vai
falar de outra coisa e tal não assinada
com isto e que eu tenho sempre muita
muita vontade a falar com os meus alunos
porque as com meus alunos e com as
pessoas em geral e no teatro porque acho
que é um momento que nos condiciona que
é o medo o medo nos disse normalmente eu
vi estes graus cheia de medo o medo é
uma uma realidade uma coisa que nos
controla condiciona que nos muitas vezes
permite ou não fazer determinadas coisas
e e eo medo muitas vezes o que nós
fazemos é ignorá lo tipo sentindo
qualquer coisa aqui uma coisa que
apertassem qualquer coisa mas fazemos de
conta que não está ali inventar
desculpas para não ter que enfrentar e
eu descobri que para talvez quem por
causa da minha competência para para ser
um pouco louca e fazer coisas que não
não só a muito custo maior
descobri que a relação com o medo me
ajudou a ter uma noção completamente
diferente como trabalho com vida porque
porque o medo muitas vezes é uma coisa
que construir um pronunciamento o mesma
função biológica que é proteger - o medo
existe para que nós nos punimos uma
situação de perigo e nossa vida não seja
destruída por um lobo que nos vai no
comércio por exemplo o medo tem uma
função importante mas depois no nosso
contexto social e psicológico muitas
vezes essa essa função é acaba por ser
prejudicial
o medo faz é criar exagerar terminado as
circunstâncias para nós nos colocarmos
uma situação que não se aumente a taxa
que vai colocar em perigo e quando nós
fazemos um exercício de dizer eu tenho
medo estou cheio de medo mas eu vou
fazer isto
a maior parte das vezes descobrimos que
era menos assustador do que nós
pensávamos que as consequências mesmo
quando quando acontece aquilo que nós
achávamos que o normal não são tão
graves como isso e principalmente
percebemos que o olhar é que o permite
continuar a jovem falou aquilo foi um
lance é uma coisa que nós muitas vezes
dizemos mas na prática cada vez menos
nos damos prioridade falhar é porque não
nos permitimos ter um espaço vazio de
risco real
o espaço fazendo isso quer dizer eu numa
situação eu sei que estando aqui estou
aqui convosco e que se eu não preparar e
por exemplo esta tese de uma maneira
eficaz pode correr mal e coloco nesse
estado nessa situação de risco porque
quero tentar ir mais longe
quero tentar superar uma dificuldade
quer tentar entrar numa relação de
frente comigo e convosco
nós temos verificado em fazer isso no
mundo nos permite não dar muito espaço e
pesados dizerem rr era depois vai a o
fim das contas o que conta é média que a
entrada é notinha o fim do período é
é tudo inúmeros em números em números é
isso que no final embora alguns digam
não o importante é olhar o bebê falhar
mas falhar em usar a outro em média mais
alta portanto este modelo que disse que
o frango nesse sentido mas para vocês
que como eu de como alguém diz ao carro
jogo é mais uma vez que foi incrementada
pela apresentação jogo da noite quando
foi fazer a selphy nós somos os
protagonistas da nossa vida e
independentemente do que viram e do que
do que dizem isso e ter sucesso não tem
sucesso os s importante é que você tem o
fim do dia quando foi dormir e não deixe
que o medo seja vocês bicho papão cruz
que os impedem de avançar em quatro
minutos então dá pra contar uma história
medo já vi muitas histórias de medo ao
longo da minha vida
como disse eu tenho tendência para fazer
coisas um casulo maluca quando era miúda
mais de uma vez foi acompanhada em
situações um carinho perigosas que o
próprio não sei explicar como é que
aconteceram uma delas foi a via eu nessa
altura estava em casa da minha avó em
barcelos ou dos céus e terra legal
estava em casa da minha avó ea com ela
camioneta para a cidade ela vive numa
aldeia e ao pé da paragem da camioneta
havia um cão muito muito muito próximo a
gravar daqui os mesmos violento estava
preso por uma corrente mas que era assim
mesmo é muito perigoso a gente tinha
muito medo ele afastava se que o cão o
colocamos na altura a minha voz à
conquistá la com uma vizinha na boa e de
repente não sabe minha adaptação ainda
que está sólido e tassoni e vão andar
comigo é fazer festinhas no campo estava
e eu lhe a vida do cão fazer festinhas e
o candidato tranquila brincar comigo
porque eu fiz isso não sei mas nem eu
nem lembro muito bem mas de repente ouço
por aí com certeza o medo qualquer
porque sente mais atraída pelo cão fazer
festas o cão e isso funcionou muito bem
que é uma coisa tão incrível é que
quanto mais desejamos uma coisa mais
metemos e o problema de
nos venderam ao medo é quase sempre
aquilo que sacrificamos são as coisas
que nós mais de anos quanto mais nós
queremos uma coisa mais medo isso nos
faz tentar ir atrás dela e outra
história é tamanho da minha infância que
eu acho que é uma das nossas maiores
ênfases são inspirações para para muitos
momentos de crise a nossa vida lembra
estilista muitas vezes lá atrás há uma
memória que nos salva quando desde os
hotéis que nos seus livros é eu estou eu
tenho dois irmãos ou mais nova estamos
em que passamos muito tempo sozinhos em
casa porque meus pais trabalham e nós
pessoas comuns para casa e ficamos
sozinhos não acata é o menor dessas
coisas e então os meus pais têm umas
regras para que a casa não fosse
destruída aí teve quase para ser uma
tropa que entendemos a casa outras
quatro que não diz a casa deve haver
regras muito rígidas pelos manter
seguros e os banhos também mais ou menos
surge um dia minha mãe gostava muito do
mimosas que são aquelas flores amarelas
têm que o cheiro muito intenso que
aparecem no fim do inverno sabem assim
nos montes aos 26 grechi e decidiu
trazer uma jarra enorme de mimosas para
casa oito categorias e então trouxe uma
jóia de flores e povo nessa aula
mas como eu acham que o tóxico é que tem
que ser realmente muito intenso é minha
mãe era uma história para tentar que nós
não tivéssemos limitou-se a questão com
os imóveis íris não se aproxime de
mimosa estejam mais famosas e lembrem se
uma pessoa ficar fechada dentro de um
quarto pequeno sem janelas muito tempo
com as mimosas podem morrer
isso foi o suficiente para a minha
cabeça e começar a congeminar eudes
morrer ele mas moss carlos dentro de um
quarto chat com um jato mimosas maps
israel
então um dia quando os meus pais não
estavam em casa eu agarro juro de
mimosas vou pra casa de banho que não
têm janelas fechou a chave está o meu
irmão lado for a bater na porta a chorar
as horas a eleito vai morrer mas disse
que o tumor
e ele sai do lado de dentro a dizer
espero que a gente mexe bem e não senti
nada não senti nada por aí
aí parei eu acho que não eu acho que não
eu acho que não está acontecendo aguenta
muito esse belo monte tempo com as
mimosas de ver o que acontecia
finalmente sair e convém não morri
uribe é e eu acho que essa essa com
muitas outras é uma história que me
permitiu ter o que acontece quando nós
fazemos isso enfrentamos o medo é que
fique uma mora em nosso corpo nosso
espírito que nos diz 2 capaz de
enfrentar isso
e que no tempo e se torna um hábito ou
seja as coisas não se resolvem de um dia
pra noite não acredita quando disserem
otp magia amanhã está tudo resolvido
vida tá tá resolvido não as coisas
importantes do valor são construídas com
tempo com muito tempo mas eu percebi
naquele momento quando sobre viagens as
mimosas que que ficam para toda a vida
que eu podia continuar a desafiar meu
medo é importante ver vocês faz xixi
dentro de uma casa bem com jamie moss e
vou ver que não acontece nada
obrigado
[Música]